here's another quick tutorial on how to
ruin the rest of your life step one
close your body language go throughout
life with a closed body language slouch
your shoulders keep your head down don't
make eye cont
don't give anybody the impression that
you're someone they can talk to or
someone they can trust appearing
socially unreceptive will reduce the
amount of friends you make and keep
spontaneous human interaction to a
minimum which is great now hopefully
everyone can just get out of your way
and leave you
alone step two check your phone when in
doubt check your phone even if you don't
know why always look occupied so you
don't have to interact with anybody
you're not comfortable interacting with
it could be awkward or unpredictable so
don't risk it tickle your brain stem
whenever you don't know what to do make
this your default do it so often that
you genuinely forget how people are
supposed to interact further solidifying
this automatic Behavior step three be
late never be early to anything always
tend to show up right on time or a few
minutes late don't give anybody the
impression that you're prepared diligent
or have decent time management skills
you don't want to come across as too
Keen plus being early is awkward what if
you have to talk with somebody you don't
really know like what are you going to
do make a new friend anyways when you do
run late or make any kind of mistake in
life you should always make excuses
always have some sort of half-baked
reason why you did a bad thing blame
something anything but yourself never
own up to your mistakes or try earnestly
to correct them just cycle through a
rotation of excuses and keep track of
how recently you've used them the bottom
line is that you should never admit that
your wrongdoing is your fault even when
you know it is lose track of the last
time you apologized number five develop
an external locus of control begin to
actually believe that nothing is your
fault choose to believe that everything
in your life happens to you and nothing
because of you that you had no part to
play in your Mis Fortune doing this will
trick your subconscious into
relinquishing control of your fortune as
well you'll begin to believe that
success will just happen to
you step six steal the spotlight always
find a way to steer the conversation
back to yourself whatever story you just
heard isn't as crazy as that thing that
happened to you that one time never ask
anybody how they're doing and if you do
out of courtesy take the mic back as
soon as possible after all how are you
supposed to get any validation without
talking about yourself and you need as
much validation as you can get acting
this way around other people will make
you so exhausting to be around that
you'll find yourself slowly losing
friends instead of gaining them step
seven detract on the off chance that
you're not talking about yourself make
sure to talk about others in a negative
light especially if you can find someone
else who shares your toxicity cackle and
sneer at people you don't like convince
yourself that they should know better
become so proficient at noticing the
flaws in others that it becomes an
automatic reflex let any celebration or
words of affirmation sour in your wake
serve every compliment on your backhand
step eight shape shift say one thing do
another act one way in front of others
and another way behind closed Doors live
your life as if you're several different
people be unpredictable even to yourself
a chameleon whatever you need to be at
any given moment be so unfamiliar with
your own moral standards that you lose
any sense of identity step nine wish
Never Surrender yourself to the effort
of planning or the humility of prayer
simply wish for things to be different
fantasize daily about your perfect world
and your perfect life reject the card
you've been dealt refuse to play an
active role in the shaping of your
destiny just wait for the night in
shining armor to come prancing down the
hill step 10 shrink regularly
participate in activities that steal
your life don't engage in behaviors that
make you feel strong always take the
path of least resistance convince
yourself that what's good for you is bad
and what's bad for you is good Step 11
despair believe that you are Unworthy of
redemption that somehow your flaws are
unforgivable actively reject your own
forgiveness subscribe to the idea that
no matter what you do you're destined
for condemnation believe that you are
fundamentally bad and since human beings
tend to act according to what they
believe they are this will make it much
easier to continue doing bad things it's
just who you are live your life as if
you've been dead for 20 years and it's
already too late to change
anything You Had Your
Shot it's
over thank you to ag1 for sponsoring
this video you all probably know by now
that ag1 is my favorite supplement and
that's because there's almost no
competing with its nutritional profile
it's packed with 75 vitamins minerals
and Whole Food sourced ingredients in
every single scoop ag1 is by far the
simplest simp way that I've found to
help keep my body and mind feeling
energized and optimized throughout the
day I also find that since it's sourced
from Whole Foods it's extremely
bioavailable which means that when I
take ag1 it feels like my body can
actually absorb it instead of just
urinating it all out like so many
cheaper multivitamins so if you're
interested in joining me in this very
simple Health optimization habit that
I've been doing for almost 3 years now
then if you use my link in the
description below you'll also get a year
supply of their vitamin D3 and K2
complex as well as five ag1 travel packs
with your first purchase so make sure to
check out that link and thanks again to
ag1 for sponsoring this
[Music]
video